- [Voiceover] Let's see
if we can figure out
the product of x minus
four and x plus seven.
And we want to write that product
in standard quadratic form
which is just a fancy way of saying a form
where you have some coefficient
on the second degree term,
a x squared plus some coefficient b
on the first degree term
plus the constant term.
So this right over here would
be standard quadratic form.
So that's the form that we
want to express this product in
and encourage you to pause the video
and try to work through it on your own.
Alright, now let's work through this.
And the key when we're multiplying
two binomials like this,
or actually when you're
multiplying any polynomials,
is just to remember the
distributive property
that we all by this point know quite well.
So what we could view this is as
is we could distribute this x minus four,
this entire expression
over the x and the seven.
So we could say that
this is the same thing
as x minus four times x
plus x minus four times seven.
So let's write that.
So x minus four times x,
or we could write this
as x times x minus four.
That's distributing, or multiplying
the x minus four times x
that's right there.
Plus seven times x minus four.
Times x minus four.
Notice all we did is
distribute the x minus four.
We took this whole thing
and we multiplied it
by each term over here.
We multiplied x by x minus four
and we multiplied seven by x minus four.
Now, we see that we have these,
I guess you can call
them two seperate terms.
And to simplify each of them,
or to multiply them out,
we just have to distribute.
In this first we're going to
have to distribute this blue x.
And over here we have to
distribute this blue seven.
So let's do that.
So here we can say x times
x is going to be x squared.
X times, we have a negative here,
so we can say negative four is
going to be negative four x.
And just like, that we get
x squared minus four x.
And then over here we have seven times x
so that's going to be plus seven x.
And then we have seven
times the negative four
which is negative 28.
And we are almost done.
We can simplify it a little bit more.
We have two first degree terms here.
If I have negative four xs
and to that I add seven xs,
what is that going to be?
Well those two terms together,
these two terms together are going to be
negative four plus seven xs.
Negative four plus, plus seven.
Negative four plus seven xs.
So all I'm doing here,
I'm making it very clear
that I'm adding these two coefficients,
and then we have all of the other terms.
We have the x squared.
X squared plus this and then we have,
and then we have the minus,
and then we have the minus 28.
And we're at the home stretch!
This would simply to x squared.
Now negative four plus seven is three,
so this is going to be plus three x.
That's what these two middle
terms simplify to, to three x.
And then we have minus 28.
Minus 28.
And just like that, we are done!
And a fun thing to think about,
since it's in the same form.
If we were to compare a is one,
b is three, and c is -28,
but it's interesting here
to look at the pattern
when we multiplied these two binomials.
Especially these two binomials
where the coefficient
on the x term was a one.
Notice we have x times x,
that what actually forms the
x squared term over here.
We have negative four, let
me do this in a new color.
We have negative four times,
that's not a new color.
We have,
we have negative four times seven,
which is going to be negative 28.
And then how did we get this middle term?
How did we get this three x?
Well, you had the negative
four x plus the seven x.
Or the negative four
plus the seven times x.
You had the negative four plus the seven,
So I hope you see a little
bit of a pattern here.
If you're multiplying two binomials
where the coefficients on
the x term are both one.
It's going to be x squared.
And then the last term, the constant term,
is going to be the product
of these two constants.
Negative four and seven.
And then the first degree
term right over here,
it's coefficient is going to be the sum
of these two constants,
negative four and seven.
Now this might, you could do
this pattern if you practice it.
It's just something that will help you
multiply binomials a little bit faster.
But it's super important that
you realize where this came from.
This came from nothing more than
applying the distributive property twice.